como parte del proceso de contratación
una compañía revisa si los solicitantes
de trabajo consumen sustancias ilegales
la prueba que usan tiene una tasa de
'falso positivo' del 2% y una tasa de
falso negativo del 1% supón que un 5% de
los solicitantes consume sustancias
ilegales y elegimos de manera aleatoria
a un solicitante dado que la prueba del
solicitante da positivo cuál es la
probabilidad de que realmente consumas
sustancias ilegales primero vamos a
asegurarnos de comprender lo que nos
están diciendo hay una prueba anti
drogas que aplican a los solicitantes de
trabajo y esta prueba tiene una tasa de
falso positivo del 2% qué significa esto
significa que el 2% de los casos en que
el resultado debía ser negativo porque
la persona no consume drogas
el resultado da positivo por eso se le
llama falso positivo porque debió ser
negativo pero vio positivo otra forma de
pensar en esto es que cuando alguien que
no usa drogas
y que esta prueba existirá un 2% de
probabilidad de que el resultado salga
positivo para uso de drogas también nos
dicen que hay una tasa de falso negativo
del 1% qué significa esto significa que
un 1% de las veces una persona que si
consume sustancias ilícitas tendrá un
resultado negativo por eso se le dice
falso negativo ya que debió haber dado
un resultado positivo finalmente nos
dicen que el 5% de los solicitantes si
consumen sustancias ilegales hay varias
formas en las que podemos pensar en esto
una de las formas más sencillas de
conceptualizar esto es inventar una gran
cantidad de solicitantes una cantidad
que sea bastante sencilla para calcular
matemáticamente digamos que comenzamos
con 10.000 solicitantes simplemente
elegí esta cantidad porque es bastante
sencilla de operar a diferencia de
cantidades como 9.283
estos son el 100 por ciento de mis
solicitantes aquí nos están dando datos
importantes nos dicen que el 5 por
ciento de todos los solicitantes si
consumen sustancias ilícitas así que
podemos descomponer esta cantidad en dos
grupos los que consumen drogas y los que
no el 5 por ciento consumen drogas y 95%
no consumen drogas
cuál es el 5 por ciento de 10.000 son
500 que usan drogas el 5 por ciento de
nuestra población
cuántos no consumen drogas 9.500 o 95%
ahora vamos a aplicarles la prueba que
va a pasar cuando apliquemos la prueba a
las personas que si consumen droga
idealmente la prueba daría un resultado
positivo para todos ellos pero sabemos
que no es una prueba perfecta y dará un
falso negativo para algunos de ellos y
sabemos esto porque nos dicen que la
tasa de falso negativo es de un 1% así
que de estos 500 el 99% va a tener
correcto cuál es el 99 por ciento de 500
van a ser 495 los que tengan resultado
positivo y será el 1% o cinco
solicitantes los que tendrán un falso
negativo si nos preguntan qué porcentaje
de los solicitantes originales consumen
drogas y tienen un resultado positivo
será 495 entre 10.000 que es 4.95 por
ciento que el porcentaje de los
solicitantes originales consume drogas
pero tiene un resultado negativo en la
prueba el 5 entre 10.000 que nos da 0.05
por ciento otra forma en la que podemos
obtener estos porcentajes es tomar el 5%
y multiplicarlo por el 1% nos va a dar
0.05 por ciento si tomamos 5% y lo
multiplicamos por 99 por ciento vamos a
tener 4 puntos 95 por ciento ahora
veamos a los solicitantes que no
consumen drogas que eso
tenemos los 'falsos positivos' la tasa
de falsos positivos es del 2% así que el
2% tendrá como resultado un falso
positivo
cuál es el 2% de 9.500 190 son los que
tendrán resultado positivo aun cuando no
consuman drogas es la tasa del falso
positivo y el otro 98% dará resultado
negativo como debe ser
9500 menos 190 nos da 9 mil 310
solicitantes con el resultado negativo
correcto qué porcentaje de la población
original es esto
190 es 1.9 por ciento que podemos
calcular como 190 entre 10.000 lo que
podemos decir que el 2% del 95% es 1.9
por ciento de nuevo multiplicamos la
ruta en el árbol que porcentajes 9.310
va a ser 93 punto 10 por ciento que
podemos calcular dividiendo 9.310 entre
10.000
multiplicando los porcentajes en esta
ruta de árbol de probabilidad 95% por 98
por ciento es 93 punto 10 por ciento y
creo que ahora ya estamos listos para
responder a la pregunta
dado que la prueba del solicitante da
positivo cuál es la probabilidad de que
realmente consuma sustancias ilegales
veamos la primera parte
dado que la prueba del solicitante da
positivo aquí tenemos a estos 495
solicitantes con un resultado positivo
correcto y aquí tenemos a estos 190 que
tuvieron resultado positivo incorrecto
cuando estuvieron resultado positivo en
total 495 + 190 y cuántos de ellos si
consumen drogas del total 495 si
consumen drogas hacemos el cálculo 495
entre 495 + 190 nos da 0.7 226
que es aproximadamente el 72 por ciento
esto es muy interesante dado que la
prueba del solicitante da positivo cuál
es la probabilidad de que realmente
consuma sustancias ilegales la cuestión
aquí con estas tasas de falsos positivos
y falsos negativos es que parecen muy
bajas pero ahora que hicimos los
cálculos la probabilidad de que alguien
si esté consumiendo drogas es alta pero
no tan alta no es como que si tiene un
resultado positivo sea definitivo que
consume drogas y también podemos llegar
a este resultado simplemente
multiplicando los porcentajes por
ejemplo podemos pensar en términos del
porcentaje de que los solicitantes
originales tengan resultados positivos
4.95 por ciento más 1.9 por ciento y de
estos qué porcentaje si consume drogas
pues el 4.95 por ciento vean que estas
operaciones nos dan exactamente el mismo
resultado
es interesante porque de las personas
que tuvieron pruebas con resultado
positivo el 72% de ellos si consume
drogas también podríamos verlo desde
otro punto de vista de las personas que
tuvieron resultado positivo en la prueba
495 190 que el porcentaje no consume
drogas 190 y esta operación nos dará
aproximadamente 28% 100% menos 72%
imaginen que un solicitante tuvo un
resultado positivo y se encuentra en un
juzgado el abogado del fiscal dice que
la prueba es muy buena porque tiene una
tasa de falso positivo de 2% así que es
casi seguro de que esta persona consume
drogas y alguien que no se haya
molestado en hacer todos estos cálculos
podría estar de acuerdo con el abogado
pero cuando vemos esto nos damos cuenta
de que aunque la prueba haya sido
positiva hay un 28% de probabilidad de
que esta persona no esté consumiendo
drogas
en este grupo de 'falso positivo' y la
razón por la cual este número es más
grande que este otro número es porque en
esta dirección entre los que sí consumen
drogas y los que no lo hacen la mayor
parte de los solicitantes no consumen
drogas por lo que el 2% de este grupo
más grande de los que no consumen drogas
va a ser un número grande en comparación
con el porcentaje de los que si consumen
drogas y tienen resultado positivo esto
es fascinante y no solo para este caso
en particular sino que vemos análisis
como este en todas partes cuando se
trata de determinar si cierta medicina o
cierto procedimiento es efectivo es por
eso que es importante poder hacer estos
análisis